salut aujourd'hui c'est le jour du blog
mais je vous emmène pas dehors je vous
emmène dedans et plus précisément dans
mes abonnements de youtube il ya quatre
mois maintenant c'était le 17 mars
dernier je vous faisait découvrir les
cinq chaînes qui me faisait vraiment
tripé je les suis toujours elle me
plaisent toujours autant et aujourd'hui
je vous en fait découvrir des nouvelles
que j'aime particulièrement
une nouvelle chaîne que j'aime bien
qu'il commence à se mettre en place et
la chaîne du mnémo note c'est david qui
fait ça comme son nom l'indiqué c'est
une chaîne dédiée à la mémoire il n'a
pas forcément les mêmes angles d'attaqué
que moi ou les mêmes présentations c'est
vraiment 100% sur la mémoire avec des
applications hyper concret il a lancé la
chaîne ya trois mois il a 146 abonnés
pour le moment mais tous ceux et celles
d'entre vous qui s'intéressent à la
mémoire vous allez y trouver des trucs
une chaîne qui me plaît beaucoup c'est
la chaîne d'une pote marimba ou son vous
l'avez vu dans une de mes premières
vidéos tout début de l'année en ce
moment elle est au festival d'avignon et
à chaque fois qu'elle est au festival
d'avignon elle fait des épisodes la base
sur place pour pâques à l'eau c'est
toujours très drôle c'est bien écrit
c'est bien filmé c'est bien tourné
aujourd'hui je me suis aperçue qu'elle
avait que 600 abonnés alors qu'elle est
sur youtube depuis tellement longtemps
et elle fait des trucs vraiment cool
vous pourrez regarder les anciennes
vidéos qu'elle faisait pour pâques à
l'eau qui sont très écrits et cette
année c'est un petit peu différent
puisqu'elle blogs sont avignon mais ça
reste très gros et en plus dans les
vidéos on voit plein d'humoristes qu'on
aime bien donc ça c'est cool
l'une de mes scènes préférées c'est la
chaîne de crise de poissons fécond son
idée c'est de faire des vidéos qui sont
plutôt instructive mais j'aime bien le
traitement j'aime bien la manière de
s'exprimer qui est plutôt calme
d'ailleurs le travail de recherche est
cool c'est bien écrit encore une fois
c'est bien tourner c'est bien monté et
j'aime bien les chaînes qui développe un
univers complet comme on peut le
constater il n'a pas vraiment besoin que
je parle de be pour être sur youtube
game puisqu'il a un million et quelques
d'abonnés mais comme je vous parle des
chaînes que je kiffe j'ai pas pris comme
une restriction le nombre d'abonnés il
ya une chaîne qui est assez récente
aussi c'est celle de l'ex tutor enfin
quand je dis assez récente avait plus
vieille que le mental blog je crois
qu'il avait eu un petit coup de pouce de
la chaîne de brousse de y penser c'est
comme ça que j'avais découvert c'est un
avocat en fait qui fait une chaîne il ya
plusieurs séries mais celle que je
préfère celle qui s'appelle cgt ou en
tant qu'avocat il va traiter d'un sujet
qui pourrait être un sujet légal comme
cette vidéo tuer un zombie est il un
meurtre ça a été ma bonne découverte de
cette année sur youtube parce que je
vais jamais vu deux chaînes qui parlait
de loi et en mélangeant c'est avec
l'humour et avec un contenu aussi
intéressant et pour terminer la chaîne
d'un autre pote qui s'appelle max birds
c'est un pote qui est sur scène à la
base et le but de sa chaîne c'est de
détruire les idées reçues et c'est très
drôle c'est bien fait c'est intelligent
et c'est très drôle
ça fait un moment qu'il était dans ma
liste des chaînes dont je voulais vous
parler quand j'allais faire cette vidéo
sauf que quand
le moment où j'ai décidé d'écrire cette
vidéo il avait 4000 et le moment où je
la fais là 129000 as a encore monté
c'est ouf 129000 abonnés donc il a pris
125 mille abonnés en moins d'une semaine
pour deux raisons la première c'est
parce que doc cbl lui a fait une mise en
avant sur sa chaîne l'excellente celle
de doc seven aussi que je vous
recommande soit dit en passant est la
deuxième raison c'est parce que sa
chaîne est vraiment qualitatif je crois
que c'est une des plus grosses entrées
dans le youtube game apparemment j'ai lu
ça dans un article et bien je vous la
présente également la chaîne de max
allez voir voilà j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu si vous avez d'autres
chaînes que vous qui fait vraiment pas
de l'autopromo des chaînes que vous
aimez vraiment bien que voulait nous
faire découvrir la team menthe à l'eau
n'hésitez pas à le mettre dans les
commentaires quant à moi je mettrais les
cinq chaînes dont je vous ai parlé dans
le descriptif personnellement ça m'a
fait plaisir de vous faire un blog un
petit peu différent c'est pas vraiment
enveloppe puisque je vous emmène dans
mon ordinateur mais je trouvais que ça
change un petit peu le rythme si jamais
ça vous a plu faites le moi savoir en
laissant un magnifique et bloguant pouce
en l'air
elle est jouée utilise un petit peu sur
cette semaine demain je mentalise un mec
qui s'appelle victor barange mercredi
parce que vous ne l'avez demandé je vous
donne des astuces pour ce faire
augmenter ou pour négocier je vais voir
calanques je vais prendre suis en train
d'écrire
et je dis je fais la foire aux questions
pour fêter les trente mille abonnés si
vous avez une question n'hésitez pas à
nous la poser sur twitter mettant le
hashtag mentalisme 30000 le mentalisme
du futur
vous êtes nombreux à m'avoir demandé
pourquoi on faisait la faq sur twitter
alors je vais vous le dire pour deux
raisons la première c'est parce qu'à
chaque fois que je fais quelque chose
avec vous j'ai c'est de changer de
réseau social pour pénaliser personne
donc un coup c'est facebook un coup
c'est instagram un coup cessna pas
couché twitter et la deuxième raison
c'est que vous n'êtes peut-être pas sans
savoir que depuis début juillet depuis
le premier jour et je n'ai plus internet
j'ai changé d'opérateur pour prendre la
fibre de chefferies et ça ne fonctionne
toujours pas je crois qu'ils m'ont
complètement oublié malgré mes relances
et mes appels
d'ailleurs si jamais il y en a un ou une
d'entre vous qui travaillent chez free
qui peut m'aider à faire accélérer ça
parce que c'est pas possible en fait je
en train de tout télécharger en 4g et
c'est ce qui m'amène à pourquoi j'ai pas
fait une erreur fait qu'ils se nomment
chat par exemple parce que j'ai trop
peur en fait que c'est un vent trop et
jora de beauce nappe
bref si vous travaillez chez free
contactez moi ça me ferait grand plaisir
qu'on puisse résoudre ça parce que quand
tu mets une vidéo par jour bâle as envie
de te jeter par la fenêtre
et comme ce road show c'est ça sert à
rien et si vous avez une question
relative à mes vidéos en général ou à
youtube vous mettez la question sur
twitter avec le hashtag passé une
excellente semaine n'oubliez pas de vous
abonner avant de partir et rendez vous
demain a dit
d'ailleurs ciao
moi